[Music]
so the other day as walking through town
square when I ran into Karla you guys
have all met her right she's in our
class so I did the usual hey oh my god I
feel like I've never seen outside of
class how are you and I was expecting
the usual great so busy how are you but
instead I got something different I got
a good but can I get your help on
something it's like every good GSB
student I was like yeah of course how
can I help you
so we started talking about brand
pipeline priorities and the whole time
I'm thinking Carlos got this why does
she need my help so finally I asked for
it was like Karla let me just see this
what what's going on
suddenly it all made sense in an
industry that is marked by how many
times someone's gonna swipe right on you
or accept it was obvious that her
strategy wasn't working so like any
other good GSB student I did my research
checked out the market and saw Carla's
not alone there are a lot of other
people with the same problem in strategy
see they know their brand but they're
having an issue of effectively
communicating it online so as a self
self-proclaimed matchmaker I decided
let's share some tips namely 1 make sure
you've got a strong powerful photo to
grab their attention with a headline or
tagline and 3 close the deal with a
conversation now Bruno I know what
you're thinking right now I'm already
married I don't need this
unfortunately there are other types of
online presences too just LinkedIn
ringabel I've come a long way since that
first attempt at an online presence and
now I'm fully prepared to share with all
of you how to impress if you're a power
picture so why is this important a photo
is worth a thousand words we make
sweeping judgments about others based
off of our body language and our facial
expressions a study conducted at
Princeton showed that judgments of
political candidates facial expressions
in just one second can predict seventy
percent of US Senate race outcomes and
of course you never get a second chance
to make that first impression so your
power photo cats I have two tactical
tips for how to go about selecting that
power picture first of all make sure
that your personal brand is reflected in
your picture whether through your
clothing or through your appearance now
in selecting our what type of picture
we'll come across with our personal
brand let's think through a couple of
examples right how does this actually
come across in practice I took the
liberty of downloading a few photos off
of the GSB faculty website
in order for us to go through a couple
of examples for how this might come
across in practice for example JD's
glasses may give the impression that he
is smart Alison's hair is fabulous and
gives the impression that she's polished
and poised and while Burt's sepia filter
might leave something to be desired no
denying there's something edgy about his
collar
okay so now that we've discussed how to
reflect your personal personal brand in
that power photo let's consider how to
convey trustworthiness and confidence in
your power picture
Amy Cuddy's research shows that 80 to
90% of a first impression is comprised
of confidence and trustworthiness so how
do we convey confidence and
trustworthiness in a photo well first
make yourself big to demonstrate power
if you have a photo where your legs are
crossed your arms are crossed shoulders
hunched it may appear submissive and as
we've heard in Kara alters credibility
code don't tilt your chin down because
that may come across as deferential or
shy and don't tilt your chin too high up
in the air because that may come across
as being arrogant or cocky quite
literally remain level-headed in some
when you're selecting your power photo
make sure that you're reflecting your
personal brand and that you convey a
sense of confidence and trustworthy in
your power picture thanks Cara for
reminding me always being authentic and
decent appearance and on top of the
pictures tip line is also very important
to grab people's attention why is so
important a tag line affects your brand
so first sometimes pictures are not
available like in your resume their
attack line is your first chance to
describe yourself and secondly by
knowing your audience and passing your
relevant information to your audience a
tag line can be a hook to keep people
interesting you answered in some of the
web websites like GSP website
and everybody is wearing a similar suit
with a similar authentic smile the
attack line is a chance to differentiate
yourself words make power so how to make
a powerful headline so here I'm using
myself an example to highlight three
tips how to make a tagline tip number
one describe who you are make it
relevant and interesting to communicate
with clarity 3 keep it a short big idea
first so here's my first tagline maybe
really experienced sales leader in
high-tech industry and overseas country
manager currently dot dot dot this is a
bad one obviously and it's not relevant
and interesting as a tagline online
dating software it's not clear for the
audience and it's too long so here I
come out with my second one passionate
entrepreneur with a love for spot balls
and meatballs much better
so finally once you've got your own
tagline you can double check with your
friends your peers no mentors and any of
your potential audience to make sure
your tagline is relevant interesting
it's clear it's short and finally it's
powerful
great so now we have your attention with
the tagline it's time to close the deal
with conversation just to make sure we
are all on the same page closing the
deal it's a business term meaning to get
that sale but it's also term we use
meaning to get the date or get the
meeting if we're talking about LinkedIn
so why is conversation important
conversation can either make or break
your credibility the conversation is a
two-way exchange of information and we
know in business that two-way exchange
of information helps us to identify the
customers needs the customers at
citation and creates a connection with
the customer now Ron Willingham who
wrote the book authenticity the head
heart and soul of selling says that
connection is the first and most
important point in effective selling and
that's basically what you're doing here
you're selling your personal brand the
second reason why conversation is so
important is because it adds a little
color to personality what you say the
words you use even how long it might
take you to respond I'll say something
about your personal brand and that's a
narrative that you have the ability to
control so how do we converse
effectively the first is an introduction
for example something like you up it's
actually a valid question for some
late-night apps but probably not the
best introduction when you're trying to
find your future significant other so
that is our first point start with an
appropriate introduction know your
audience and just to be clear you up is
never appropriate on LinkedIn now you
have the appropriate introduction you're
in it's time to converse and that leads
us to our second tip practice effective
listening even with online communication
good listeners are better sellers than
good talkers so ask them questions about
their profile ask them about their
interests and try to keep them
open-ended to make it more engaging I'm
going to let you all in on a little
secret people love to talk about
themselves in fact my favorite topic is
me research from Harvard University
suggests that self disclosure and
talking about herself actually elicits
internal pleasure so to keep them
talking about themselves you are already
on your way to success and our third
point here close video and with a
specific next step sometimes when we're
pitching or when we're in conversations
we're so focused on what we're gonna say
and how we're gonna say it that we
actually forget to ask for what we want
so be confident and ask for that
specific next step they can't say yes to
your date but you don't actually ask for
one speaking of that date
we have given you three ways that you
can effectively communicate online and
we've given you some game-changing tips
along the way we've talked about the
first impression and the importance of a
power picture one that needs to be
trustworthy and confident and then we
talked about grabbing their attention
with the tagline making sure it's clear
relevance and concise and finally we
talked about closing the deal with
conversation have your appropriate
introduction make sure you're
effectively listening and finally ask
for what you want so we are not miracle
workers here but we do think that if you
follow these three steps you will know
the answer to the question will they
swipe right and with that the
matchmakers of the class were happy to
answer any questions you may have the
rest
[Music]